on a reçu des stars françaises mais
aussi des stars internationales
je vous dis ces deux grognards qui avait
été le premier invité regarde jamais
pleinement mandat tonnerre
un genre ont besoin de ça et tu leur
donnes
alors ça ça fait plaisir
[Applaudissements]
lenny kravitz est situé très mauvais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baba
m
vraiment regardé tous les arbitres et
pour la russie ce qui donne à urt ah
ouais ouais
impressionnant d'invités qui vous a le
plus marqué est vous qui vous n'avez pas
eu alors qu'il vomissait pas gérer
j'aurais aimé avoir johnny hallyday je
vous dis voilà franchement johnny
j'aurais aimé l'avoir parce que c'était
vraiment un gros grand fan de johnny
normalement il faut bel - celui je
voudrais c'est jean paul belmondo ici
que je l'aimais énormément je vous ai
phocéen
well on s'aime beaucoup avec jean-paul
et j'espère qu'un jour il viendra si
c'est que c était son anniversaire la
cette semaine je souhaite un très bon
anniversaire à jean-paul il sait que je
laime très très fort ils ont balancé un
peu ou pas ouais c'est luc tellement
aimé lundi que j'ai le moins aimé et
bien français me dit panaméricains qu'on
verra jamais il n'y a eu ni vers hélène
non non non non il y en avait un qui ai
mis beaucoup je sais que tu vas me dire
qu'ils vincent elbaz oui exactement
j'aimais beaucoup ça va tourner avec lui
dans la vérité si je mens et tous et il
est venu ici il est eroglu 2000 même vu
s'en est rendu compte
mais il est très sympa dans l'abîmé dans
l'émission il sait il s'est pas sentie
soit là mais bon voilà c'est ces voix là
mais sinon il est très sympa de gérer
quelqu'un qui vous a refusé devant fin
qui a refusé de venir et ça vous a
blessé
vous auriez vraiment y avait deux
personnes
alors j'aimerais j'aimerais aussi
beaucoup recevoir bernard tapie le c'est
bernard comme je les aime énormément
voilà je pense fort à lui aussi est mais
sinon quelqu'un vraiment qui c'est les
menus a refusé d'en dernièrement je vais
vous dire le dernier cas est refusé de
venir parce que je les aime beaucoup ses
édiles de preto ah oui moi il y ait des
idées préconçues
merci lui
il aime beaucoup jouer qui viennent
chanter voilà et donc j'espère qu'il
viendra un jour